[موسيقى]
عند وصولي إلى لشبونة ، لن أضيع
وقتك في القفز مباشرة إلى
[موسيقى]
حتى ترى تنوراتهم عبارة عن سلال
ولديهم سردين داخل التنانير ،
يجب عليك قراءة كل شيء لأنه
غني جدًا ،
إنها أكبر ليلة في  السنة
في المدينة التي تعد أحدث عاصمة أوروبا
الرائعة ، عيد القديس أنتوني ،
شفيع لشبونة ، قديس الأشياء المفقودة
والذي يتضمن بشكل مثير للسخرية
الحب والزواج ، نحن ذاهبون في فيلا بيرتا
وهو المكان المناسب ليكون في مكان مركزي ،
مرحبًا  هنا
جوانا باريوس معروفة جيدًا
أنك عام ، نعم
[تصفيق]
لقد كتبت كتباً
اسمًا مألوفًا
عندما تمشي في الشوارع
يحييها الناس مثل الأصدقاء القدامى
لذلك يتم تكرار هذا في جميع أنحاء لشبونة
الليلة أوليفر أه معظم الأحياء
الأحياء النموذجية ما هي
أهمية كل هذا بالنسبة لك ،
هذا بالنسبة لي أه حقًا نابض بالحياة
وأم إنها طريقة لطيفة جدًا للاحتفال
بتقاليدك كشخص برتغالي
تستمتع به مع  إذا كان الشعور بالذنب
بسبب الملذات المذنبة ،
فمن دواعي سروري أن الموسيقى هي
متعة مذنب ، الطعام هو
متعة مذنب حتى الفولكلور الذي
نحتفل به هنا يمكن أن يُنظر إليه على أنه
Kitsch أو Camp لديك سردين على
مطبخك.  المعسكر أنا هناك
أرمي السردين ولدينا
مقومات الطبيعة تذكر
أن رائحة السردين تنقع في
هواء لشبونة ولا أستطيع أن أكون أكثر سعادة ، أنا أحب
السردين الذي ستلتزم به ملابسي لعدة
أيام ، سيكون مجرد إلقاء نظرة جيدة على ذلك.
أحب عيد الميلاد المذاق المالح ، لذلك
دعونا نحصل على القليل من آداب السردين ،
نعم ، حتى تحصل على شوكة لذلك تأكلها باستخدام
أداة ، فأنت لا تريد نوعًا ما لا ، أعني
أنه يجب عليك نزع رؤوسهم
أولاً ولكن عليك أولاً أن تضربها
هكذا نفقد
الشحوم والآن تحاول تقشيرها ،
إنها رائعة يا
[موسيقى]
سأرى هذا في كل
مكان ، أليس كذلك ما هي
الورقة التي تراها نعم إنها ريحان صغير
من عائلة الريحان
لذا إذا ذهبت فقط أشم رائحته  في ورطة
، لا تفعل من فضلك لا لا
لأن عليك لمسها ثم
شمها
تظهر بعض الاحترام
[موسيقى]
حتى الآن كنا في حفلات الحي
الآن علينا أن نشق طريقنا
الشوارع إلى الحدث الرئيسي ،
المسيرات الشعبية ، العرض الرسمي ،
عمدة لشبونة في متناول اليد ليتمنى لنا جميعًا
مثل هذا التقليد ، أعني أننا كنا
هنا منذ عام 1932 حيث لدينا هذا
الحفل وهو مثل العرض الكبير لا يوجد
شيء  مثل هذا في أوروبا وقد
عشت حولها ، لذا فهي فريدة جدًا من نوعها هذه
هي روح لشبونة ، ما هي روح
ألما البرتغالية
، الهدف هنا هو إظهار
روح الحي الذي تعيش فيه
مفعمًا بالألوان الحيوية والفخر وفرصة
لإظهار ذلك  لا يزال الجميع هنا مرحبًا بكم في
لشبونة ، إنه ممتع للغاية
ولم تروا أي شيء حتى الآن إذا لم أكن
مخطئًا ، فهذه المجموعة الأولى نعم
التي تقدم عرضها ، نعم
إنها الأولى
بعد ساعة ونصف الساعة على
الأرجح في شهر مارس  يمضي
ولا ينام أحد
إنها تبدو جادة للغاية ، حيث يتم
الحكم عليهم بناءً على موسيقى الرقص
والأزياء. أحب التفاصيل
الكاملة لحوض السباحة ، والسراويل
والطبقات المختلفة للتنانير التي تم
إجراؤها جسديًا ، انتبه إلى التفاصيل
عندما تؤدي أداءً
لرئيس البرتغال ، فالمسابقة هي
شرس السيد الرئيس ، سامحني ،
سامحتي غير الرسمية ، تبدو
مختلفًا ، هذا صحيح كم هو جميل ، يا
لها من فرصة رائعة
أخيرًا في العامين الماضيين
بعد عامين ولشبونة تبحث
للتو ، إنها بداية جديدة ،
بداية أفضل ، لا يمكننا استخدام هذا
الشرطي  بالنسبة للناس بعد
الوباء ويمكنك أن تشعر أنه يمكنك أن تشعر بأن النهاية
سعيدة
تمامًا بفرحة لا يمكن احتواؤها أو
وضعها في الفراش ، انظر إلى الأمر يستحق كل هذا
العناء ، إنه نابض بالحياة ، إنه غني بالألوان ، لذا
فهذه لعبة كلاسيكية.  متعب ، أنا
متعب ، هناك خوف من أن يفوتك
أن يكون الشخص التالي
رائعًا بشكل هزة الجماع ، لا تترك
هناك ، يجب أن تكون رائعًا بدوني.  أو
أنا متعب
، لم أستطع تركك بمفردك انظر
هنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية